Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Si je vous dis
synonyme, homonyme, règle de 3,
circulation sanguine, démographie.
Évidemment, ça vous parle.
Mais quand il s'agit de développer
un peu, de donner des chiffres,
des noms, alors là, ça coince un peu.
Et pourtant, ce sont des notions
que nous avons acquises au collège.
Il y a quelques semaines,
nous sommes revenus ensemble
sur différents éléments
du programme de 6ème.
Visiblement, la vidéo vous a plu.
Alors on continue, mais cette fois,
on retourne en 5ème.
Coucou, on va commencer par les maths !
La règle de 3, ça vous parle ?
Alors c'est une règle très simple
dont on se sert tous les jours
sans même s'en rendre compte.
En cuisine, notamment,
quand il faut calculer
la quantité d'ingrédients à utiliser
pour une recette.
Par exemple.
Le Paris-Brest,
c'est ma pâtisserie préférée.
Je l'achète souvent chez mon pâtissier,
mais il m'arrive
de temps en temps de la confectionner
moi-même.
Alors, dans la recette du Paris-Brest,
il y a un ingrédient incontournable :
Le pralin.
En général,
quand je prépare un
Paris-Brest, je le fais pour
6 personnes.
Dans ce cas, j'utilise
120 grammes
de pralin.
C'est bon.
Maintenant, imaginez que je doive
préparer un Paris-Brest géant
pour une classe de 5ème de
31 élèves.
Quelle quantité de pralin
va t-il me falloir ?
C'est une excellente une question.
Eh bien, c'est là
que la règle de 3 devient très utile.
D'abord, il faut savoir quelle
quantité de pralin est nécessaire
pour 1 personne.
S'il me faut 120 grammes de pralin pour 6,
pour 1 personne, on divise
120 par 6.
Résultat
20 grammes.
Pour confectionner un Paris-Brest
pour 31 élèves, il va donc falloir
31 fois 20 grammes,
soit 620 grammes
de pralin.
On parle de règle de 3.
Non pas parce que cette règle a été mise
au point pendant la guerre de Troie
ou dans la ville de Troye,
mais tout simplement
parce qu'elle fait intervenir
3 chiffres
6, 120
et 31.
Je ne pensais pas que les maths pouvaient ouvrir autant l'appétit.
Beau, joli, cantine, réfectoire, baraque...
maison.
Ça devrait suffire.
Voilà des mots, du langage courant.
Vous n'avez d'ailleurs aucune difficulté
à remplacer l'un par l'autre.
Ce sont des synonymes.
Sandwich et casse-croûte ?
Exactement.
Yes !
Ces mots ne s'écrivent pas
de la même manière,
mais ils ont la même signification.
Dans la langue française,
il y en a des milliers
et c'est bien pratique
pour éviter les répétitions.
Mais il faut quand même s'en méfier
car ils ne veulent pas toujours dire
exactement la même chose.
Alors quand les mots ont le même sens,
ce sont des synonymes.
Mais quand ils disent le contraire,
ce sont des antonymes.
Un bon élève, un mauvais élève.
La langue française
compte plus de 20000 antonymes.
Beau, laid, grand, petit.
Je ne vous dresse pas toute la liste.
Les homonymes, quant à eux, sont des mots
qui se prononcent
ou qui s'écrivent de la même manière.
Mais ils n'ont pas du tout
la même signification.
Et si c'est leur prononciation
qui est identique,
on dit qu'ils sont homophones.
Un pain : P-A-I-N
celui que l'on mange.
Et un pin : P-I-N
l'arbre.
Ils donnent souvent du fil à retordre
aux étrangers
lorsqu'ils apprennent le français.
Ce genre de phrases, par exemple,
un ver vert, va vers, un ver en verre.
À l'oreille,
Ccest un vrai casse-tête.
Et si ce n'est pas la prononciation,
mais l'orthographe
des mots qui est identique,
on dit que les homonymes sont homographes.
En d'autres termes,
ils s'écrivent de la même manière,
mais ils se prononcent différemment.
Par exemple :
Cet homme est fier, doit-on s'en fier ?
Fier et fier.
s'écrivent de la même manière,
mais ne se prononcent pas
de la même façon.
Mais là où ça se complique,
c'est quand les homonymes peuvent être à la fois
des homophones et des homographes.
Ils se prononcent de la même façon.
Ils ont exactement la même orthographe,
mais ne veulent pas du tout dire
la même chose.
Dit comme ça, ça paraît un peu compliqué,
mais c'est très simple.
Regardez cette phrase :
le mousse gratte la mousse sur la coque du bateau.
Ou bien
Les poules du couvent couvent leurs oeufs.
Vous me suivez toujours ?
Je ne te suis plus et j'en suis désolé.
Ça marche aussi.
Pour terminer en beauté,
un petit mot :
des caconymes.
Ils désignent des noms particulièrement difficiles à porter.
Certains sont restés
célèbres dans l'Histoire,
comme l'évêque Cauchon,
qui a présidé le procès de Jeanne d'Arc,
ou encore
le chevalier de la Crotte,
qui vécu sous le règne de Louis XII.
Mais mon préféré, c'est
le nom de ce chimiste
britannique du XIXᵉ siècle,
William Prout.
En français, ça fait... prout.
Car lui, son nom est aussi un aptonyme,
un nom qui lui va bien puisque c'était
un spécialiste des gaz.
Les artères, les veines,
les ventricules, les poumons.
Tous ces mots vous rappellent forcément
de vieux souvenirs de 5ème.
Mais êtes-vous encore capable de dire
quel rôle exact jouait
chacun d'eux dans la circulation du sang ?
Allez, on remet un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça.
La circulation sanguine,
c'est un processus très complexe
qui permet d'alimenter
nos organes en dioxygène.
Dioxygène, parce que la molécule est formée
de 2 atomes d'oxygène.
Mais son rôle ne s'arrête pas là.
Le sang qui circule dans les vaisseaux
apporte également
les nutriments dont nos organes ont besoin
et les débarrasse de leurs déchets
pour qu'ils fonctionnent correctement.
L'organe clé qui est
au cœur de la circulation sanguine,
c'est lui le cœur.
Il fonctionne comme une pompe et propulse
le sang grâce à ses deux ventricules.
Le ventricule droit propulse
le sang dans l'artère pulmonaire
vers les poumons.
C'est là qu'il se charge en oxygène
et qu'il se débarrasse
du dioxyde de carbone
qu'il avait emmagasiné
avant de retourner au cœur,
par la veine pulmonaire.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la petite circulation.
Le ventricule gauche, lui, propulse
le sang oxygéné dans l'aorte.
C'est l'artère principale de notre organisme.
Elle se ramifie en différentes artères
qui transportent le sang
jusqu'aux organes.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la grande circulation.
Ça me rappelle une expérience rigolote
qu'on m'avait faite en classe
pour prendre conscience
que nos artères transportent bien le sang
du cœur vers les organes.
Il suffit de placer une balle de tennis
sous l'aisselle comme ceci.
Ensuite, on cherche son poul,
au niveau du poignet.
Et là, que se passe-t-il ?
Beh ? Je ne sens plus rien.
Je suis mort ?
C'est normal.
La balle de tennis comprime l'artère
principale de votre bras
et empêche le sang de descendre.
C'est donc bien la preuve que le sang circule
du cœur vers la main.
Une fois dans les artères,
le sang passe dans les capillaires.
Ce sont de tout petits vaisseaux
qui lui permettent de pénétrer
puis de circuler dans les organes.
Grâce à leur paroi très fine,
le dioxygène contenu dans le sang
peut passer dans les cellules
de tout l'organisme.
En échange, le sang récupère
le dioxyde de carbone
et les autres déchets.
Une fois vidé de son dioxygène,
le sang retourne au cœur
en circulant dans les veines.
Il y arrive par les veines caves,
la veine cave supérieure
et la veine cave inférieure
et passe dans l'oreillette droite.
Celle-ci se contracte
et envoie le sang dans le ventricule
droit, ici.
Puis direction les poumons afin
d'être oxygéné et débarrassé
du dioxyde de carbone.
Le sang revient ensuite
au cœur par la veine pulmonaire.
Il y arrive dans l'oreillette gauche
puis passe dans le ventricule gauche
avant d'être
à nouveau propulsé dans tout le corps.
Et c'est reparti pour un tour.
Quand j'étais en 5ème,
il y avait un peu plus de
4 milliards d'êtres humains sur Terre.
Depuis le 15 novembre 2022,
nous sommes 8 milliards.
En un peu plus de 40 ans,
ce chiffre a doublé.
C'est incroyable !
D'autant plus incroyable
que pendant des milliers d'années,
la croissance de la population mondiale
est restée assez faible.
Et depuis le début du XIXᵉ siècle,
principalement
grâce aux progrès de la médecine,
elle est exponentielle.
En 1800, la Terre comptait
environ 950 millions d'habitants.
En 1950, nous étions
2,5 milliards et aujourd'hui 8 milliards.
Mais comment on fait
pour calculer tout ça ?
Je suis sûr que vous êtes nombreux
à vous en souvenir.
C'était justement
au programme de la cinquième.
Si je vous dis recensement,
ça vous parle ?
Il consiste à compter le nombre de foyers
et de personnes qui résident dans un pays.
En France, c'est un organisme appelé
Insee qui s'en charge.
Je suis sûr que vous en avez déjà entendu
parler.
Aujourd'hui,
tous les États recensent leur population.
L'ONU a ensuite pour mission
de rassembler les données afin de parvenir,
non pas à un chiffre exact,
mais à une estimation.
Car bien sûr, il est
impossible de déterminer un chiffre exact.
En moyenne, il naît 280 bébés
toutes les minutes et il meurt 109
personnes dans le monde.
Et j'ai une petite anecdote
à vous raconter à ce sujet
qui date justement de la 5ème.
En cours de géo,
un élève avait demandé à notre prof
si elle savait combien
la Terre avait accueilli d'êtres humains
depuis qu'ils existent.
Je ne vous dis pas sa tête.
Évidemment, elle n'a pas su répondre
car à l'époque,
personne ne l'avait calculé.
Mais depuis, deux démographes,
un Américain et une Japonaise,
ont fait le calcul.
Pour y parvenir,
ils ont dû déterminer un point de départ.
Ils n'ont pas choisi l'apparition
des premiers hominidés, il y a 3
ou 4 millions d'années, mais le moment
ou ceux-ci sont devenus humains.
Ils sont partis de 190000 ans
avant notre ère.
A cette époque, nos ancêtres
n'étaient que 30000
à la surface de la planète,
à peine de quoi remplir un stade de foot.
Vous êtes bien assis.
D'après leurs calculs,
117 milliards d'humains
auraient vécu sur Terre.
Alors, la population mondiale
va continuer d'augmenter.
Elle devrait atteindre
9 milliards d'habitants
d'ici une quinzaine d'années,
avant de connaître un pic vers 2080.
Nous serons alors environ 10,4 milliards.
Oui, vous avez bien entendu
un pic, car contrairement
à ce que l'on pourrait croire,
ce chiffre ne va pas augmenter
ad vitam eternam.
D'après les spécialistes,
il devrait stagner
jusqu'en 2100 avant de diminuer
en raison
de la baisse du taux de fécondité.
Alors que dans les années 1950
1 femme avait en moyenne
5 enfants au cours de sa vie.
Aujourd'hui, ce taux est descendu à 2,3.
Il pourrait même passer sous la barre
des 2 enfants d'ici la fin du siècle.
Ce qui fait dire à certains spécialistes
que la population mondiale pourrait
non pas stagner
mais baisser de manière fulgurante
d'ici la fin du siècle.
Selon certaines projections,
elle pourrait même être divisée par 2
et redescendre
à un peu plus de
4 milliards d'êtres humains.
Comme quand j'étais en 5ème.
C'est la récré.
Alors ce retour en 5ème,
ça vous a plu ?
En tout
cas, j'espère que je vous ai permis
de faire resurgir
quelques bons souvenirs de collège.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce bleu et à vous abonner.
Et puis, si ce format
continue de vous intéresser,
eh bien la prochaine fois,
on passe en 4ème.
Merci pour votre soutien
et à très bientôt.
Chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.